Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And the,
my name is Paul students all over the English speaking world studies Shakespeare
at school, and lots of them hate it,
maybe because what the reading feels a little bit like a different language and
they can't understand it very well.
The reason the plays and poems of William Shakespeare aren't immediately easy to
understand is that they were written in early modern English between the years,
1590 and 16,
13 Shakespeare wrote at least 38 plays and over 150 poems,
both short and long. Some of these are legendary classics like Hamlet, Macbeth,
and Romeo and Juliet.
The works of William Shakespeare made a tremendous impact on Western culture.
And more importantly for us here today on the English language, of course,
there are famous lines from Shakespeare's plays like to be or not to be.
That is the question, but that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about an extensive impact on the actual vocabulary of English,
including many words that we use every day and many idiomatic expressions that
are frequently used.
It has commonly been said that Shakespeare created 1,700 words that are
commonly used in modern English.
We have to be careful with that number and the word created though,
there are many words whose first appearance in writing is in the works of
William Shakespeare.
But many of these words may have been in colloquial use at the time while
Shakespeare was just the first to use them in writing.
And some of these 1,700 words actually appeared in earlier,
but less known literature.
It might be better to say that Shakespeare popularized these words and helped
ensure their presence in modern English, as it developed.
It's hard to know exactly which words he created himself and which ones he
didn't let's start with idioms because we have a better idea of which ones
originated with Shakespeare, too much of a good thing.
This idiom first appeared in the play. As you like it,
you might be a little surprised by what thing refers to in the original context
of the play. It's um,
I guess you could say it's meaning as somewhat adult the be all and end
all meaning the most impressive or important in its category.
This city I'm first appeared in the play.
Macbeth Shakespeare used it with a somewhat different meaning.
All that is needed to end all this problems.
Macbeth is considering assassinating King Dunkin,
but wonders about the additional problems that will cause come full circle.
This first appeared in King Lear to come full circle.
It means that your actions have gone through a series of stages,
but you arrive back at your starting point in some way to have the makings of
this is an idiom,
which means to have the potential to become this city I'm comes from Henry the
eighth. She had all the Royal makings of a queen.
The original meaning was a little different though.
It meant that she possessed things that gave her the appearance of a queen.
Not that she had the potential to become a queen.
Some idioms and vocabulary introduced by Shakespeare have evolved in meaning
since then a foregone conclusion,
a term referring to a highly predictable outcome.
This is first found in the play a fellow named this was, but his dream,
but this denoted a foregone conclusion. In other words,
what happened in the dream most certainly happened in real life. And again,
what happened in the dream was something elicit of an adult nature,
neither rhyme, nor reason. This is an idiom,
meaning that something is completely lacking in logic and order.
It first appeared in writing in the comedy of errors,
but it's a translation of a similar phrase in French song, Lehman, new Hazel,
literally without rhyme or reason in modern day, English.
This idiom exists in a few variations like without rhyme or reason or no rhyme
or reason. For example, there's no rhyme or reason for his behavior,
or he managed the office without rhyme or reason. One fell swoop.
This is an idiom referring to an action completed rapidly and all at once.
It first appeared in Macbeth, all my pretty ones. Did you say all, Oh,
hell kite, all what?
All my pretty chickens and their at one fell swoop.
Macduff is talking about the murder of his family,
ordered by Macbeth and uses the metaphor of a dangerous birds swooping down to
attack. The word fel is used here with its archaic,
meaning of deadly as luck would have it.
This is an idiom indicating that something happened due to luck. For example,
I forgot my wallet at home, but as luck would have it,
there was a $20 bill in my pocket.
This first appeared in the Merry wives of Windsor.
You shall hear as good luck would have. It comes in one mistress page.
There are many more idioms like these,
some of which are mainly used in literary contexts and some of which are
commonly used in everyday language.
And there are some which are still attributed to Shakespeare,
even though earlier appearances of the idiom are now known such as it's Greek.
To me, more common these days in it's very informed. It's all Greek to me,
meaning you can't understand something at all. The vocabulary,
the vocabulary introduced by William Shakespeare,
into English developed in a few different ways.
Some words were created by combining two existing words.
The adverb upstairs is a combination of up and stairs. Similarly,
downstairs is a combination of down plus stairs, birthplace,
eyeball watchdog,
Shakespeare introduced a number of compound adjectives consisting of an
adjective and a past participle cold hearted cold blooded
well-behaved well-bred well-educated well-read ill
tempered. Some words became used in different word classes.
After English lost much of its inflection in the middle English period,
it became easy for words from one class such as noun, adjective,
or verb to be used in another class. Some verbs became used as nouns.
For example, the word bump.
It first appeared as a noun in the works of William Shakespeare,
but it existed as a verb before that similarly control.
When used as a noun and hint,
when used as a noun go between a noun referring to a middleman or liaison.
This comes from the verbal phrase go between.
And some nouns became used as verbs to torture. This first existed as a noun,
but Shakespeare used it as a verb to cater.
This is a verb meaning to supply food. This came from the middle English.
Now Katurah, meaning buyer of provisions,
many new words were created through adding affixes to existing words.
Successful.
This adjective was formed from the noun success by adding the suffix full
similarly useful is an adjective that came from the noun use.
Plus the suffix full something is full of use amazement.
The noun was formed from the verb amaze. With the addition of the suffix meant,
meant creates a noun referring to an action or the state resulting from that
action. Countless this adjective comes from the noun count.
Plus the suffix less, the suffix less indicates the absence of something.
So if something's priceless, it's too valuable for you to buy.
There's no price employer.
This is an agent now a noun for the Dewar of an action,
which was created by adding the suffix ER, to the verb employee.
And related to that is employment for this.
Now the suffix ment was added to the verb.
The state that results from the action employer.
Fashionable.
This adjective was created from the verb fashion, plus the suffix a bull.
So it means able to be fashioned. In other words, able to be given good style.
Majestic Shakespeare created the adjective from the now majesty plus the
adjective suffix it to misquote the prefix.
Miss simply adds the meaning of mistaken or wrong.
Some words were even created by removing affixes to impede.
This verb was created by removing the noun.
Forming suffix meant from impediment to negotiate.
This verb was formed by removing the non-conforming suffix shin Tio N from
negotiation. Some existing words were given a new sense. Cheap.
This word had already existed with the meaning of low price,
but Shakespeare used it with the sense of low quality or a vulgar flowery.
This word had already existed as an adjective related to flowers,
but William Shakespeare used it with the new sense of richly embellished speech.
For example, using lots of fancy adjectives,
some words were adopted from French and Latin retirement.
This word was taken from middle French hook deal originally,
meaning active retreating and active withdrawing into seclusion Shakespeare.
Didn't use it with its most common modern day meaning of coming to the end of
your working life. The word generous was taken from French Geneva,
but it originally had a different sense from now meaning gentle noble or fair.
Some words are completely original,
whether they originated in colloquial speech or Shakespeare,
created them to puke a colloquial word for.
Okay.
That this word first appeared in the slang of street criminals. But in writing,
it was first in the works of Shakespeare.
Certain common co-locations were first found in the works of Shakespeare.
For example, on purpose, the something in question,
the thing we are focusing on, for example,
the document in question something you might hear in a formal legal or business
context,
it's quite amazing that one man who wrote a collection of plays on poetry,
not only inspired our literary tradition,
but also had such a huge impact on the words we use every day,
without even realizing it.
English is now the defacto international language and people all around the
world,
including people who learn English as a second language or foreign language,
use words and idioms either created by William Shakespeare or catapulted into
the mainstream of modern English through his works.
And it's impressive on another level as well.
It's a powerful reminder that by doing things we're passionate about,
we can potentially have a long lasting impact on the world around us.
The question of the day,
which of the words and idioms in the video do you use regularly?
Did you know that they originated in the works of William Shakespeare?
Leave your answers in the comments down below a big shout out,
goes out to all of my Patrion supporters,
including these ones right here on the screen. They are my top two,
your Patrion supporters,
and that's why they appear in the video and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day visit Lang
focus.com to gain free access to an exclusive video series on how to hugely
increase your vocabulary in any language.
Simply sign up for the Lang focus newsletter and you'll receive the free video
course direct to your email.